Hey Wisecrack, Jared in the the very pale
flesh again.
So we watched Netflix’s new Death Note movie
this weekend, and thought it merited some discussion.
And, of course, some spoilers.
If you watched our video on the Death Note anime a couple weeks ago, you know that we’re big fans.
The show draws out incredibly nuanced ideas
about the nature of justice
Justice
and even participates
in its own kind of philosophical dialogue
throughout the series.
It’s just damn good television.
The movie?
Well it’s not exactly good cinema.
Ahhhhh!
Now off the bat, I just wanna say that adapting
a 37 episode anime to a single movie is really,
REALLY hard.
If somebody hired me to do that I’d be s***ing
my pants, so we’re not here to grade how
closely the new film sticks to the anime or
the manga.
It’s an adaptation, and it deserves some
room to do its own thing.
So let’s look at the film on its own terms.
It’s definitely got some good things going
for it, and the thing that I most admire is
its attempt to preserve some of the thematic
richness of the anime, which is an impressive
goal for a 100-minute movie that already packs
in a lot— action sequences, detective games,
gore, and teen romance.
From Light’s argument that his systematic
cheating is no big deal
I'm looking at homework here for at least 15 different students.
All right, I get it. I'm in trouble.
All I'm trying to say is you have the chance to stop the type of people who make things hard for everybody.
You got to see the big picture here.
To his conversation with his dad at the end,
Death Note tries to put some moral ambiguity
into Light’s character and to gesture to
bigger questions about the nature of good and evil.
Given the time constraints, it was smart not
to attempt the massive discourses on justice
that we see in the anime.
But the film makes clear that it’s still
interested in ethics, just in a simplified form.
What exactly can I do with this death note?
Put your name down, and see what happens.
Unfortunately, that’s where the film gets
itself into trouble.
Toward the beginning, Mr. Turner tells Light
Here, of course, he’s talking about the
role of the Seattle police.
But Light seems to adopt a similar principle.
Using the power of the Death Note, he— like
his anime counterpart— wants to create a
new world where innocent civilians are protected
from the “people who make life miserable.”
The Death Note is his gun, and that’s the
aim.
Although he gets squeamish about offing some
law enforcement, we never really see Light
compromising the intentions behind that aim
until his David Copperfield reveal at the end of the film.
Instead, they bring in a seductive, power-hungry
girlfriend to play the role of bad cop.
For 90% of the movie, Light is unambiguously
the good guy, or at least the kind-of-okay guy.
And that’s a problem.
Kira largely had the support of the people,
including the police, until the death of the FBI team.
And who sent eight federal agents walking
off a building?
The duplicitous Mia.
Who stole the notebook from Light and wrote
his name in it?
Bad, bad Mia.
Who killed Watari by not burning the page
with his name on it?
We’re clearly supposed to blame Mia… even
though Light put him in there in the first place.
Although the film spends next to no time developing
what Light wants out of his new world, he’s
still shockingly quick to abandon it once
someone dies who hasn’t committed a felony
or stolen someone’s lunch money.
Do you really think people are gonna be on their knees if you can talk to Kira like that?
We're not killing my dad! Mia, this is over. Will you f*** this? We're not the good guys anymore.
“We aren’t the good guys anymore” sounds a lot more like “people don’t like us”
than an actual statement about Kira’s morality
of Rule.
And while the third act of the film tries
to play up the difference between Light’s
reluctance to kill people and Bad Mia’s
bloodthirstiness, Light’s shift seems more
pragmatic than anything.
Light’s change of perspective isn’t an
indication that there was ever problems with
his plan for becoming a God, just that the
circumstances have changed and he doesn’t
want to go to prison but Mia doesn’t really
mind.
If a gun is only as good as its aim, it seems
like the film should be asking questions about
Light’s aim with the Death Note.
But instead of saying “Be careful of aiming
your gun in this direction,” it’s more
“make sure your crazy girlfriend doesn’t
get ahold of your gun.”
Give me my f***ing book, okay?!
Even L’s quick personality flip from “I
don’t kill; I bring people to justice”
to “I might kill you in the same way you
killed hundreds of people” seems to be totally
dependent on circumstance.
The detective’s strong moral framework,
developed since childhood, gets tossed away
instantly when his friend goes missing—
but there’s no emphasis on the significance
of that change.
Light ends the film by telling his dad
But what are these two evils?
My guess is that not even Light knows.
Unlike the anime—I know, sorry, I had to say it—
Death Note’s ethical ambiguity is less about
opening a multitude of possibilities and more
about shrugging in the direction of good and evil,
while ultimately saying nothing.
(evil laughter and depressing music)
What?
You humans are so...interesting (evil laughter)
Now, once again, condensing an anime of that magnitude into a relatively short film is a difficult
task, and I won’t begrudge the filmmakers
some reductions in depth.
But what the story clung to most— questions
about good and evil— was poorly executed
and ended up hamstringing its potential, both
philosophically and dramatically.
Anyway, those are our thoughts.
We’re still experimenting with this new
quicktake format, so if you have thoughts
on what we should cover next, let us know.
Peace guys.